[Aplausos]
cómo estás
estoy increíble emocionado
por tener la oportunidad de estar aquí
frente a ustedes para poder compartirles
esto acerca de jóvenes de emprendimiento
está
quiero que piensen en la edad que tienen
actualmente en esta etapa de la vida
por ejemplo la mayoría aquí ustedes son
jóvenes quiero que piensen en esta edad
en la que nuestro principal objetivo
tu principal
responsabilidad en la vida es
cumplir
con satisfacer
las necesidades tus necesidades propias
como ser humano esta época en la vida en
la que realmente no tenemos dependientes
en la que poca gente puede depender de
ti mismo
es unidad es una edad sumamente
relevante 16 17 18 años 20 25 y 29 años
en méxico se considera joven a toda
persona
tenga entre 12 a 29 años
y simplemente quiero que pienses en tus
sueños en tus anhelos
en tu vida en lo que haces
jugar divertirte pensar trabajar
en algunos casos y en otros tantos
estudiar
lo que
lo que caracteriza a prácticamente todos
ustedes es que en esta edad
es cuando definen qué es lo que harán
hacia dónde se perfilan en su vida
algunos de ustedes
quieren ser doctores psicólogas
arquitectos ingenieros etcétera
este es el momento de su vida
y la invitación es
al menos desde mi perspectiva vamos por
la vida voy por la vida
pensando que todo tiene una fórmula
mágica una receta en la que primero
estudió primaria secundaria preparatoria
y universidad licenciatura un posgrado
trabajo
hoy tengo una pareja me caso tengo hijos
y así sigo mi vida como si fuera toda
una fórmula
mi invitación es a que paren a que hagan
una pausa si quieren vivir de esta forma
está increíble que bueno que lo quieran
hacer sino también el punto es que hagan
conciencia de cómo están viviendo en
este momento
requerimos hacer las cosas a conciencia
requerimos entender como juventud que
para llegar a una meta
requiero pasar por ciertas cosas
no todo en la vida me va a gustar
actualmente no tenemos tolerancia a la
frustración cuando no me gusta algo lo
botó no me interesa
digo no más esto no es para mí creemos
que las relaciones son desechables que
las personas son desechables
y no hablo no habló específicamente
igual algunos de ustedes no pero en
general como sociedad estamos en esta
época en esta época de la inmediatez por
ejemplo si alguno de ustedes aquí quiere
ser ingeniero
pues para alcanzar este sueño
pues pasarán por muchísimas cosas muchas
materias algunas les gustarán si quiere
ser ingeniero seguramente te gustan las
matemáticas te gusta la física la
estática estructuras pero habrá muchas
otras que no te gusten materias de
economía
materias de redacción español si también
en una carrera aún en una carrera
técnica se ve en esas materias
entonces habrá materias que te gusten y
habrá materias que no
pero es parte de tu meta de ser
ingeniero es tan grande ese es tu sueño
que estás dispuesto a pasar por eso y
más a pasar por
hacia lo que te guste lo que no te gusta
en ese proceso y esa es la invitación a
que si ustedes tienen un sueño en esta
vida algo por qué luchar
pues exactamente vayan por eso
en el tema de jóvenes en mexico
de inicio en méxico tenemos 123.5
millones de habitantes
el 50 por ciento aproximadamente
y recién nacido 0 años hasta los 29 años
vivimos un momento histórico un momento
histórico en el que el bono demográfico
el bono demográfico es cuando tenemos
esos en todo el mundo cuando tenemos a
personas entre 14 y 49 años de edad en
edad productiva en edad de trabajar en
edad de ser poco dependientes quienes
son los dependientes dependientes son
niños y personas de la tercera edad
entonces requerimos aprovechar este bono
demográfico y que está pasando la
mayoría de los jóvenes
no están teniendo esas oportunidades no
estamos creando estas oportunidades para
los jóvenes el 85%
de los jóvenes perciben salarios menores
a seis mil pesos mensuales muchos de
ellos sin seguridad social muchos de
ellos
prestaciones
y la otra estadística también es fuerte
uno de cada diez jóvenes está
desempleado
entonces qué está pasando tenemos
jóvenes desempleados tenemos jóvenes
que están recibiendo poco dinero por su
trabajo y no por ello hacen menos
simplemente tienen tienen salarios medio
tiempo tiempo completo trabajos en los
que hacen exactamente igual a veces
hasta más
entonces tenemos una situación crítica
en méxico
y esto que le estoy compartiendo no es
para que se desanimen y digan bueno
entonces me voy a ir del país o qué hago
no ese no es el punto el punto es que
seamos conscientes de la realidad actual
esto está pasando en mi país que puedo
hacer para solucionar esto
en términos de gente que de personas de
jóvenes que están estudiando
licenciaturas
carreras técnicas educación
media-superior
la estadística es fuerte sólo tres de
cada cinco están teniendo empleos
formales dos de ellos dos de estos cinco
se están yendo directamente a la
informalidad en la que pocas veces
pueden pasar de la informalidad a la
formalidad
aquí aquí tenemos una cifra fuerte la
movilidad social en este país es
prácticamente nula sólo 2% de todos
estos jóvenes pueden moverse
clase media por así decirlo para que
puedan alcanzar una media media alta o
alta solamente el 2% tiene esa
posibilidad a diferencia de países
comunidad como inglaterra eeuu francia
donde las tasas la mínima va del 18%
hasta el 28% en algunos de ellos
entonces sí requerimos crear todo este
entorno
aquí mi propuesta
que emprendamos no nos queda de otra
nosotros los jóvenes la sociedad como
tal requerimos generar las condiciones
de trabajo que no existen actualmente
requerimos poner nuestras empresas poner
nuestros negocios
y aquí les quiero platicar cómo inició
como inicié como emprendedor
estudié arquitectura
[Música]
una parte la estoy aquí en pachuca otra
parte en la ciudad de mexico y obtuve mi
título universitario esto fue en verano
del 2011 de ahí hice estudios en estado
estudios en comunidades sustentables
después regresó a méxico a principios
del 2012 y digo ahora sí alarme tengo
título en mano tengo aparte de ello
estudios especializados
y la sorpresa fue que al mandar mi
currículum a todas estas empresas mandé
currículum a 30 empresas despachos de
arquitectura
y solamente obtuve respuesta de 4
pues cuál fue su respuesta
te damos el trabajo esto es aceptado
pero el trabajo era
exactamente la misma paga
al menos en la arquitectura no es así
me estaban ofreciendo un trabajo que yo
ya tenía cuando estuve en octavo noveno
y décimo semestre
cuando pasaban jornadas laborales de 8
horas donde muchas veces se superaban y
me quedaba hasta las 10 11 de la noche
en este despacho
me llevaba trabajo en mi casa me
desvelaba los fines de semana
igual trabajaba
era mi descanso
entonces obviamente no lo acepte dije no
yo no puedo aceptar esto digo tampoco
dice
bueno simplemente les di las gracias y
dije voy a emprender voy a poner mi
negocio voy a poner mi despacho de
arquitectura
en marzo del 2012 con el eje
arquitectura y diseño
iniciamos bueno prácticamente inicial
comenzamos haciendo diseños y ya digo
comenzamos porque finalmente
sería nada sin la gente que lo permite
comenzamos
en distintos proyectos
de locales locales comerciales
de ahí pasé a la formalidad en esa parte
formal
un año después con mi familia creamos
una empresa constituimos una empresa
crea tu espacio punto mx con el que
elaboró hasta ahorita
y bueno ya desarrollamos más cosas ya no
solo trabajo en lo que es pachuca ciudad
de mexico ya también trabajamos en
distintos estados ya que el punto no es
que les venga a platicar todo lo que he
hecho
ese no es el punto el punto es que vean
ustedes que tengan un ejemplo ejemplo
tan tangible de que se puede de que si
yo tengo una idea de negocio una idea de
cómo arrancar mi empresa es posible
y claro que claro que ganes muchas veces
igual a sus seis mil pesos algunas veces
lo supere
ahí vamos pero el punto es que vean que
si se puede
quiero
quiero comentarles acerca de esto
se dan muchísimos apoyos para iniciar tu
empresa así como yo inicié actualmente
desde gobierno o instituciones privadas
públicas en línea de startups
incubadoras institutos universidades
todo mundo está fomentando que
emprendamos porque obviamente ellos
conocen las cifras que les acabo de
compartir
ellos saben que no hay trabajo para
todos no requerimos crearlo y está bien
así se hacen las así se generan la
riqueza así se hacen las naciones esto
pasa en todos los países primer mundo
etcétera en todos los países pasa
el tema aquí consideró que no se le da
una estructura a este emprendimiento
se apoya para que inicies te apoyan para
que haga su acta constitutiva para que
generes desde tu logo página web
etcétera pero no te están no están
apoyando las empresas que ya están
consolidadas y más allá del dinero no es
el dinero es crear todo un ecosistema en
el que nos vinculemos nos vinculamos
tanto las empresas como lo
como la gente que está comprando quien
está requiriendo ese producto
y bueno les comparto presido una
organización de emprendedores
empresarios a nivel nacional de esta
asociación
tenemos capítulos comisiones en 60
ciudades del país en 60 distintas
delegaciones
somos cientos de jóvenes de todas las
ramas sectores sector automotriz
alimentos construcción
etcétera
y con ellos bueno a partir de todo este
tiempo de estos últimos cinco años me
dado a la tarea de compilar todos estos
puntos
estas recomendaciones para poder
estructurar tu negocio
puntos para emprender estructurada mente
no se detengan en lo básico no se
detengan no pasen meses digo es una
invitación no pasen meses creando página
web el logo mi misión visión
y lo digo por experiencia estuve en un
curso en el que llevamos meses y no
pasábamos de esto simplemente avienten
se con lo que sigue sino si no operan si
no buscan como tal un producto algo como
implementar todo esto que están creando
simplemente este emprendimiento pues
seguramente va a fracasar
segundo punto productos y proveedores
igual de importantes que sus clientes si
ustedes no cuidan al proveedor a todos
ellos a todas esas personas a todos esos
esas empresas que les están
brindando
todo para hacer el producto que venden
si no cuidan a esta cadena de suministro
obviamente por ende no van a descuidar a
su cliente si ustedes no tienen un buen
producto para descuidar al cliente todos
son igual de importantes y a veces hasta
más cuidemos a nuestros proveedores
paguemos leyes a tiempo
tercero conoce a tus clientes
es real el cliente tiene la razón si hay
que cuidarlo
pero cuando tú tienes un buen producto
el cliente llega solo y conoce a tus
clientes va más allá actualmente se
considera que para emprender simplemente
subo todas las redes sociales lo subo al
facebook los water a instagram ya vendí
pues no en realidad no está tan saturada
las redes sociales de información que
poca gente se va a detener a ver
exactamente qué estás haciendo
como trabajar en una sociedad empresa en
familia simplemente cada uno de ustedes
tiene que tener roles que hago si todo
se enciman en roles obviamente esto va a
fracasar trabaja en equipo con tus
colaboradores consideren los
colaboradores no son empleados si los
consideran colaboradores que van a
cuidar se van a sentir parte del negocio
el dinero es importante sí sí lo es pero
más importante el bien común que tu
gente se sienta integrada
ponte una meta financieramente tangible
yo le recomiendo mucho que para poder
arrancar
tengan el capital de seis meses de
operación de la empresa y así se vayan
poniendo metas en utilidades
en compra de productos
inventarios 8
registra lo que pasa en tu empresa si no
registras no se puede medir no se puede
evaluar esto es muy importante siempre
números todo registrado
conoce actualiza estudia este tipo de
eventos funciona para eso para que
ustedes se empapen sobre lo que está
pasando en el mundo si no se actualizan
de verdad están perdidos
integrante de un equipo asociación de
emprendedores y empresarios digo yo lo
recomiendo desde mi experiencia y la
verdad es que digo al menos para mí es
útil tengo siete años en este camino de
poner mi empresa de trabajar
independiente y la verdad me ha servido
mucho sirve más allá de las relaciones
que pueda hacer que si las haces sirve
como ese grupo de apoyo en el que hay
gente como tú que está compartiendo y
viviendo lo mismo que tú
genera relaciones todo el tiempo y bien
simplemente muchos le dirán que en este
momento no se puede que es complicado
igual y su familia igual que ustedes
mismos se boicotean igual y para
emprender creen que requieren esos 50
mil pesos 100 mil pesos un millón
ahorrados pues si se detienen por todos
esos porqués y como nunca van a
emprender nunca van a poner su negocio
para emprender se requiere decisión y se
requiere actuar viaje
pero háganlo estructuradamente
si bien genera en comunidad de verdad es
importantísimo eso
mucha gente les dirá ahorita no joven yo
les digo ahorita si joven ahora sí joven
emprendamos a conciencia gracias
[Aplausos]